we could see another rough day on Wall
Street today after China's newest
announcement on tariffs it's ready to
tax another fifty billion dollars worth
of u.s. goods in retaliation for similar
tariffs on Chinese goods that the White
House revealed yesterday Ben Tracy is in
Beijing where the odds of a trade war
just went up dramatically Ben good
morning a good morning so China just
took its gloves off and is now
threatened to hit US imports where it
will really hurt the Chinese government
is saying that it will put a 25% tariff
on 106 US products including soybeans
corn aircrafts and automobiles now this
is very bad news for farmers in places
like Iowa and for big US companies like
Boeing in all the tariffs total 50
billion dollars now that's the same
amount the US is proposing on about
1,300 Chinese products including medical
devices semiconductors and televisions
now last week we asked the US ambassador
to China terry branstad about a trade
war with China something President Trump
says would be good and easy to win do
you think a trade war with China would
be good and do you think it would be
easy to win I don't want to see a trade
war I want to see us work together to
resolve these differences so you don't
think a trade war would be good no I
think it would be better to work these
things out now China says it still wants
to negotiate with the US and there are
no start dates for these tariffs so as
of now these are still threats viana
threats going after agriculture and
aerospace two of the us's biggest
exports been traci we will be watching
this thank you